I want to keep talking about trade for
now though we've been talking a ton
about this trade fiasco that's been
caused by Donald Trump and it's actually
a problem with many of our allies but
right now it's acutely a problem with
Canada and most of our conversations are
either about trade sort of generally
we've talked about the sources of the
tariffs that actually exists between the
United States and Canada some of the
Canadian tariffs on US products are a
response to either US tariffs or US
subsidies as I spoke about with the
dairy industry we've talked about the
trade balance that something Donald
Trump also really likes to talk about
we've also explored Donald Trump's
general and competence on trade but one
thing we haven't talked about yet is
another way in which the entire thing
can blow up in Donald Trump's pee face
which it's likely to do and that's
called boycotts
a Canadian boycott of both American
products and of traveling to the United
States has started slowly but especially
over the last ten to 14 days is building
more and more there's another movement
that is focused specifically on
encouraging a Canadian 's not to travel
to the United States to cancel their
planned travel to the United States and
many Canadians are actually doing it and
there are Canadian websites that provide
information to Canadians about whether
products are made in the United States
or not so that Canadians can if they
want to opt for the non American
products and when I tell you about this
I know that I'm gonna get right-wing
nuts
emailing me saying David go back to
Argentina or Israel or wherever it is
you're from and stop taking pleasure in
the boycotting of American businesses
and I'm not reporting it to you because
I'm taking pleasure in it I'm reporting
it to you because it pains me and I want
to stop it we we need to have a total
stop to the ruining of our ji'er
geopolitical relationships by Donald
Trump this isn't fun and games right
jobs depend on what Trump tweets and his
harebrained ideas people's livelihoods
depend on the actions of the president
and I hate
to break it to you but it's not just
Canadian tourists that are bailing on
traveling to the United States we told
you in January of 2018 about travel data
from 2017 to the United States and a lot
of countries are drastically reducing
their travel to the United States the
u.s. can manage without it's not going
to end the United in the United States
economy but jobs are going to be lost
and it won't be good for the economy the
data for 2017 was that 4.6 billion
dollars and about 40,000 jobs were lost
as a result of other countries citizens
reducing their tourism to the United
States much of that attributed of course
to the presidency of Donald Trump and I
hate the boycotts the boycotts are bad
for friends of mine who own businesses
they're bad for people I don't even know
I mean can you imagine I can actually
empathize with people that I don't even
know and it's bad for them but this
could be an effective way to state to
take a stand if people do it we know
that bookings in Trump's hotels even
Trump branded hotels not owned by Trump
but where the name is licensed to Trump
have been taking a hit I have family
very anecdotally in Argentina that is
specifically saying you know we usually
go to the US every two or three years
we're due for that but we're not gonna
go we're gonna go elsewhere because we
simply don't want to go when Donald
Trump is President of the United States
if you're wondering whether Trump even
cares I kind of doubt it I kind of doubt
it and it's yet another way in which he
said he was gonna look out for the
little guy he said he was gonna look out
for the middle man oh the middle class
but it's just not happening and so far
it doesn't actually seem like his
supporters are punishing him for it and
that's the scariest thing in the context
of the upcoming midterm elections and
I'm going to talk about that a little
bit later in the program
join the discussion with more than 6,000
of our viewers and listeners on our
subreddit trade a big topic of
discussion there as well as Paul
Manafort going to jail and lots of the
other things we discussed on today's
show david pakman.com slash re d di t is
where you find
subreddit quick break new-and-improved
shorter breaks on the David Pakman show
coming up next welcome to the program
joining you from very very sunny very
hot Northampton Massachusetts today we
have not only indictments now but also
jailings of Trump staff in the Trump
Russia investigation and it's not going
away and it's not ending anytime soon
former Trump campaign manager Paul
Manafort has been sent to jail and Paul
Manafort you might recall was previously
indicted released on bail I told you
last week he was re-indict 'add for
witness tampering charges he was
contacting people apparently via text
voice and also encrypted message and
trying to influence what they were going
to be telling investigators and he has
been charged and a judge has now sent
him to jail judge Amy Berman Jackson
said quote this isn't middle school I
can't take away his cell phone if I tell
him not to call 56 witnesses will he
call the 57 and he is now in jail and
we're gonna get to Donald Trump's
reaction in a moment but I do want to
remind you that all along we were told
nothing will ever come of this right
there's nothing to look into there will
be no charges
there will be no indictments there will
be certainly nobody going to jail or to
prison and of course pretrial detention
which is what Paul Manafort finds
himself in at this point is not prison
in the sense of a sentence but it is
somebody being held in jail because they
simply weren't able to just behave like
an adult and follow simple instructions
from the judge which include don't start
contacting witnesses and potential
witnesses and influencing their
testimony which is exactly what he did
Trump immediately both defending man
affort with logical fallacies but also
part of the idea is to distance from
mana for and we'll get to that in a
little bit Donald Trump saying it's
wrong to send Paul Manafort to jail
because he has worked for other
presidents and actually in one tweet
which I'm going to show you Donald Trump
it's amazing I know that now there's 280
characters in in a tweet instead of 140
Trump has four glaring errors including
multiple logical fallacies in just one
tweet Trump tweeting Wow
what a tough sentence for Paul Manafort
who has represented Ronald Reagan Bob
Dole and many other top political people
and campaigns didn't know manna for was
the head of the mob and what about and
he says what about Comey
and crooked Hillary and all of the
others very unfair so let's break this
down piece by piece because it's
actually in a sense it's remarkable that
he's able to insert so much nonsense
into one tweet first of all Trump says
that this is a sentence for Paul
Manafort men afford hasn't been
sentenced to anything right men afford
is being held pretrial because of his
behavior and a judge's decision to call
this a sentence confirms I was going to
say demonstrates but it actually
confirms the fundamental total lack of
understanding of the American justice
system that Donald Trump has secondly
Trump says that this is wrong to do to
Paul Manafort because manna for worked
for Ronald Reagan that's an ad hominem
genetic fallacy and you might think well
David ad hominem is when you insult
someone instead of dealing with the
argument ad hominem just means to the
man right it means that it's it could be
a positive or negative statement about
an individual in this case it happens to
be positive but it's the same fallacy as
saying oxygen is bad because Hitler
breathed oxygen right that it's kind of
a silly example here it's manna fort is
good and too good for jail because he
once worked for Ronald Reagan and of
course that's totally fallacious
logically next logical fallacy is Trump
says I didn't know manna for it was the
head of the mob that is a straw man
fallacy right rather than saying why
it's wrong to send manna for it to jail
for the actual reasons manna Ford is
being sent to jail Trump is defending
manna for it by saying this guy's not a
mob boss which is not an argument
anybody made for sending pom anaphoric
to jail and then lastly logical fallacy
number three and this one tweet Trump
says what about Comey and crooked
Hillary right the idea is why is man
afford being held pretrial if neither
James Comey nor Hillary Clinton are in
jail nor prism prison and that's classic
what about ISM right James Comey and
Hillary Clinton haven't been indicted
for anything and in any case even if
they had been indicted that wouldn't
have any bearing on whether the right
decision for Paul Manafort is to hold
him pretrial because he's now accused in
a second series of indictments of
tampering with witnesses and it's also
just a really Doug dumb argument in this
case because in general people who
haven't been charged with crimes don't
get sent to jail right like that's just
it's kind of a dumb argument that
doesn't even make sense at its face and
meanwhile so that on the one hand
there's this ludicrous and laughable
defense of Paul Manafort who's now in
jail at the same time much like with
Michael Cohen the Trump attempt to
distance the campaign from their own
campaign chairman continue Trump said
during this bizarre pseudo press
conference outside of the White House
that quote manna fort has nothing to do
with our campaign there's two analyses
there one is that trumps using the
present tense right when he says manna
Ford has nothing to do with our campaign
that's technically true because manna
Ford is not currently involved with
trump's reelection campaign he's in jail
so obviously he's not currently involved
with Trump's campaign but it's a
distortion right because manna fort was
Trump's campaign chairman Menna fort ran
Donald Trump's delegate strategy which
was a big piece of how he ended up
winning by initially starting to pick up
delegates here and there during the
Republican primary and don't forget that
when it comes to Russia manna fort was
the guy who was pushing the Republican
Party to harden their stance against
Ukraine and to soften their stance on
Russia which they did right before the
the Republican National Convention in
summer of 2016 so the distancing is
totally transparent and bogus and a
really funny side note most media
outlets when Paul Manafort was sent to
jail correctly reported the
headline which is Paul Manafort sent to
jail that that's correct right Paul
Manafort jailed whatever you whatever
phrasing you want to use for at least a
while Fox News was reporting this as
Manafort pleads not guilty to witness
tampering which is accurate but it is
not at all the most relevant and
newsworthy part of the story then
relevant and newsworthy part is not only
has this guy been adult indicted
multiple times he can't even keep it
together enough while out on bail to
stay out of jail and the next thing I
want to talk with you about is the
insanity of the reactions to Paul
Manafort being sent to jail including by
Alan Dershowitz who has completely
jumped the shark over the last year and
a half there is a whole new world out
there of ways to make money online and
I'm not even talking about out and out
scams I mean just ways to make money as
someone who gives their opinion about
things on the internet on YouTube I
often get emails from people saying hey
David you know you could make a lot more
money if you took this position or that
position or if you called out this
person or that one or that idea or this
idea and I even once had a lunch meeting
with a major talk radio person I don't
want to say who it is but it's someone
from the talk radio industry
who said to me you know David if you
could double your income by pretending
to be a conservative instead of a
progressive would you do it and I said
no of course I wouldn't do that and they
said something like it's good to know
what your principles are so you know how
you want to direct your career or
something like that and nevertheless I
never had lunch with that person again
after that meeting but regardless
fortunately our show is doing well
enough that I don't need to do that
right nor would my moral compass even
allow me to concoct some kind of fake
personality or set of positions that's
not my authentic self but there are lots
of ways now that clearly are great
moneymakers and yesterday we were
talking in studio about some of them and
some of them are obvious right like
becoming a conspiracy theorist the
theories themselves don't so much matter
but the thing about conspiracy theories
is that while they won't appeal to a
huge portion of the on
or the online media audience the people
that buy into your conspiracies will
give you money because they'll see you
as having some kind of courage to tell
the truth about whatever you're talking
about so conspiracy theories are a
really big moneymaker that's one but
there's better ways another really great
way to get people to pour money into
your patreon page or whatever else get
you speaking gigs get you invited on to
other shows is to have an awakening
right you have a political awakening and
it mostly works if you go from being
progressive to conservative in some way
because when a conservative has an
awakening and becomes progressive
progressives don't see it as a miracle
we just say yeah it's common sense they
just figured out how the world works so
if you're willing to denounce your
progressivism and concoct some reason
why you're now in the conservative side
because you've seen the light that is
really good for business and you can
make a ton of money doing that and this
will get people to celebrate you as
someone who's willing to admit mistakes
and is now copping to the ultimate truth
really really profitable Pat's taking
notes on that one cuz he's interested in
that one you can also get a ton of
attention and sort of bolster your
rhetorical credentials by setting up
false debates with artificially narrow
parameters to come off as having owned
people or taken them to school on some
issue and it's even more effective if
the people are completely unskilled and
lack any experience in actual political
rhetoric so that you look really good in
alpha you'll kill it and you will
attract the ton of attention for
yourself and that's actually a good one
in general even if you're not setting up
artificially narrow debates often with
false questions just debate people who
are totally unqualified to be debating
right you will look really good in
comparison another way that you can open
the floodgates of Internet cash give
blindingly obvious advice that you'd
normally find in those discounted
self-help books that you can get for a
penny at the local use book store on
Amazon but wrap up the obvious advice in
either intellectual sounding language or
make the advice seen
counterculture or controversial in some
way if you can hint that people are
trying to suppress your ideas because
they're dangerous or they present some
kind of ultimate truth you'll make that
much more money and if none of these
idea sounds good to you a goldmine is to
provide pseudo scientific arguments to
legitimize discriminatory and
prejudicial ideas and if you can say
that actually these are the ultimate
truths that the politically correct
crowd won't admit you can retire early
on that one and race an IQ is one that
comes to mind along those lines and then
last thing if you want just a quick tip
if you're looking to become a successful
online pundit fight against identity
politics while using your own identity
right argue that identity politics is a
terrible malignancy on society and that
white Christian men are being
disenfranchised by identity politics and
that it's time to finally stand up for
white Christian men prepare for patreon
to explode if you're willing to do that
if I'm missing any let me know because I
want to help the audience make a lot of
money on YouTube as pundits I don't plan
on doing any of this stuff but these are
just some tips for people who might be
looking for ideas I think the political
reawakening one would work best for me
because I already have a platform on a
progressive show right so I'll be
leaving here shortly and you can expect
my Prager u videos to come out in a few
weeks can you imagine if there was a big
announcement where pat has seen the
light and he is denouncing his
progressive credentials and is going to
basically you ever you could actually
say you were rejoining your family's
conservatism because you've talked about
having a more conservative family and
that would I mean you would be booked by
all sorts of right-wing leaning talking
conferences and also libertarian ones it
would be a goldmine for you I'd make a
new show it would be the path
perspective or the Ford file I'd have to
think of something I like the Ford file
Ford Ford file for freedom that would be
the way or F cubed is actually that yeah
you could do it you could have shirts
that are just an F with a number three
as in cubed send me your thoughts if I'm
missing any ways to make money on
YouTube giving giving your opinion I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show I love
this store
Homeland Security Secretary Kristin
Nielsen was shouted out of a Mexican
restaurant last night by protesters who
were confronting her over the separation
from parents and the internment camps of
children I don't know how else to say it
it's the separation and the internment
of the children that the people were
protesting and the story is
exponentially better because it was a
Mexican restaurant although in reality
the facts of the story aren't
drastically different whether it's a
Mexican restaurant or an Italian
restaurant or a French restaurant all
three of those types of restaurants rely
disproportionately on immigrants from
Latin America but there's something
about it being a Mexican restaurant that
makes it that much better for me and it
was a restaurant called M xdc cocina
mexicana in Washington DC and one person
wrote to me saying that they went to a
Mexican restaurant specifically to
trigger protests the idea that this was
some well thought out idea from Kristin
Nielsen and her staff to go to a Mexican
restaurant to trigger protests so that
then they could maybe try to say we
agree with the emotions expressed by the
protesters or something like that I
don't think it's that well thought out
and we have video Nielsen seems to keep
her eyes down on her phone while the
protesting is going on shouts of shame
and if kids don't eat in peace you don't
eat in peace and it was all captured on
video check it out
[Music]
tens of thousands of people who come
here seeking asylum in the United States
separation imagine trying to deal with
that when you just want your tableside
guacamole right I mean what disrespect
and Nielsen's spokesperson tweeted after
the incident while having a work dinner
tonight the secretary and her staff
heard from a small group of protesters
who share her concern with our current
immigration laws that have created a
crisis on our southern border this has
exploded into a conversation about free
speech the normal free speech warriors
are notably silent in their defense of
the protesters other than saying that
this isn't exactly the peaceful speech
that they defend and champion they're
saying some of them that listen this is
a restaurant and you're interrupting
someone's meal and that the restaurant
is free to handle this however they want
and the restaurant did handle it however
they wanted which was to allow this to
go on the protesters went on for minute
after minute after minute and they were
not kicked out and that was a decision
that the restaurant was able to make and
you could say well this is rude or it's
disrespectful to Kristen Nielsen but
there's nothing about free speech that
says if someone's having enchiladas you
can't say whatever you want as long as
you're not physically a grieving that
individual and excuse me if I lack
empathy but I don't care that you
couldn't have a quiet dinner out she is
causing untold strife is complicit in
untold strife with this scale up of the
child
tournament camps and separations from
parents if your claim is she should be
shielded from uncomfortable speech when
she's hoping to have margaritas at M xdc
then I simply disagree with you I like
that this happened I like that the
restaurant didn't kick out the
protesters and let the protest go on for
many many minutes looked like free
speech at its best to me and I think she
has a secret service around her -
because she's a cabinet secretary of
some kind of security and so we don't
have to worry about her safety
necessarily or it looked like she was in
good hands at the very least there was
no physical risk to her whatsoever there
was no indication that the protesters
were getting physically violent and even
if they had she does have a cabinet or
whatever you would call DC Security
Secret Service I'm not exactly sure
which department it is I am again
reminded again because it happened to be
at not just a Mexican restaurant but a
restaurant in general about the late
Anthony Bourdain who pointed out many
times that there is a hypocrisy with
immigration where Latin American
immigrants disproportionately grow and
harvest a ton of the food that we eat
and then cook their fair share of it and
more at the restaurants that have
received the food that they have helped
to grow and harvest the entire service
economy of the United States would
collapse were it not for Latin American
immigrants both documented and
undocumented and we hear oh they're
stealing our jobs and they're dangerous
immigrants when it comes to the
restaurant industry they are
single-handedly keeping the industry
afloat and as far as Kristen Nielsen she
should resign I have no idea whether she
will but she should the pressure is on
her we've seen a lot of people who
should resign Scott Pruett still hasn't
resigned from the EPA there's every
indication she will stay but she should
resign and if you're gonna be complicit
in the detention of children at least
have the decency to eat your dinner at
home right yes just stay home and
defrost a pizza or something I don't
know why an attorney general would be
talking about this but Jeff Sessions
strangely and bizarrely claimed that
Nazis didn't deport Jews during the
Holocaust why is he saying
this I hope to find out in partnership
with you today in the next five or ten
minutes there's this building string of
lies about Germany from the Trump
administration yesterday I told you that
Donald Trump tweeted incorrectly that
German crime is way up the German crime
rate is actually the lowest it's been in
26 years after that Jeff Sessions was
being interviewed about the child
internment camps for migrant children by
Laura Ingraham on Fox News that program
is quite a beauty to take a page out of
Donald Trump's vocabulary and Jeff
Sessions tries to deny that what's going
on right now with children in the United
States is anything like what was
happening in Nazi concentration camps
okay that is something that he was asked
about by Laura Ingraham because the
comparison who had been made by others
Jeff Sessions says that the key
difference between what the Nazis were
doing during World War two and what the
United States is doing now is that the
Nazis were preventing the Jews from
leaving the country not deporting them
so I mean I guess that's what counts as
an explanation in Jeff Sessions mind
here's the interview from Fox News with
Laura Ingraham and before I get to that
just so you know that I know it during
the same episode of her program Laura
Ingraham referred to the internment
camps as basically summer camps for kids
it's outrageous and ridiculous I'm not
covering that today just not enough time
but that's just sort of part of the
context of this exact same episode of
her program
let's get now to the clip of Jeff
Sessions this is how your opponent's
general sessions are demagoguing in
detail let's listen I've walked down
that railroad siding where the families
were separated and that's why I used
that picture now look I I know we're not
Nazi Germany alright but there is a
commonality there this is the United
States of Germany and the United States
of America it isn't Nazi Germany and
there's a difference
and we don't take children from their
parents until now
Nazi Germany concentration camps human
rights violations Laura Bush's wade in
Michelle Obama Rosalynn Carter got all
the first lady's gone back to Eleanor
Roosevelt she's apparently weighed in as
well
general sessions uh what's going on here
well it's a real exaggeration of course
in Nazi Germany they were keeping the
Jews from leaving the country but this
is a serious matter we need to think it
through be rational and thoughtful about
it we want to allow asylum for people
who qualify for it he had a full minute
to think about what to say he had a full
minute during which he was he knew he
was going to get an opportunity to
explain why is what we're doing now not
like what the Nazis did during World War
two and the distinction he was able to
draw between knocks Nazi concentration
camps and child internment camps today
is that the Nazis were preventing Jews
from leaving where as part of what the
US is doing is deportation this is of
course as stupid as it is false the
Nazis did deport millions of Jews from
Germany and from other countries to both
concentration camps and work camps and
death camps all over Europe and included
German Jews French Jews Jews from many
countries deported unmasked to
concentration camps all over the place
Poland Czechoslovakia Germany Belgium
France it wasn't called deportation it
was called evacuation but it's the same
damn thing and that's where I get back
to even if Jeff Sessions were correct
right by choosing to say that the
difference between Nazi Germany and this
is the supposedly of deportations all
he's saying is we're doing the early
Nazi stuff and not the later Nazi stuff
because there was a point before the
Nazis started the deportations that's
not very positive but why even answer it
in that way all you say is that the
Holocaust was a unique moment in history
six to twelve million people were killed
they were taken from their homes and
gassed and starved to death
you're talking about a documented Harris
right that's all you got to do
you just say there's nothing whatsoever
that's similar and to say you know the
difference is back then they weren't
doing deportations and now we are
someone please write to me and tell me
history will not look kindly at this
please tell me that because if there is
going to be any saving grace in this
absolute abortion of an American
government that we're dealing with right
now I'm hopeful the only thing I'm
optimistic about at this point other
than cautious pseudo optimism about
maybe voting them out in November the
only thing that's in the back of my mind
as maybe something positive that could
come from this is that what we are
observing now is memorialized in history
that history will look back at this for
what it is which is a series of bumbling
atrocities and that it will hopefully
prevent it from happening again and if
there's people in the audience who
believe that that's going to happen
write to me and tell me that that's
what's going to happen and if you think
I'm wrong if you think that even that
isn't going to happen
I'd rather know the truth write to me
and tell me that as well I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show and we'll be right
back
remember when Donald Trump said if I had
done half of what she did I'd be in jail
he was talking obviously about Hillary
Clinton and it's really funny how that
comment now seems not only to have been
yet another instance of projection but
actually yet another way in which it's
Donald Trump that if he was held to the
standards that he was saying Hillary
Clinton should be held to and would be
held to would be the guy sitting in jail
and I want to remind you about Donald
Trump's much bragged about charitable
foundation right this is called the
Trump Foundation turns out that one of
the recipients of the generous charity
of the Trump foundation is Donald Trump
himself and the the the resignation of
New York Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman recently has not
interrupted the New York Attorney
General's Office work on the Trump
foundation and the pressure on the Trump
foundation continues and the new
Attorney General there Barbara Underwood
has filed a new lawsuit against Donald
Trump's charity for what's called self
dealing and self dealing
in short means that the Trump foundation
just like Trump University is a scam for
Trump's personal enrichment that's not
actually what self-dealing
is but that's sort of the gist of what
this entire thing represents for us the
lawsuit says that instead of being a
real charitable foundation the Trump
foundation was working as a bank account
that Donald Trump's accountants would
use as a checking account at any time
that Donald Trump needed money either to
settle legal disputes or sometimes if
Trump publicly made a donation pledge
Trump said I'm gonna donate to some some
such charity he wouldn't actually donate
they would just pull money out of the
trunk foundation of money that came in
from donors and make it to the charity
that Donald Trump promised a donation to
if they donated at all we know some of
them were just straight-up lies and
sometimes those political donations made
to the Trump foundation by donors were
used to facilitate campaign
contributions which is a whole other
legal problem that we're going to talk
about at some other point most famously
there's like a really big example of
this that's cited in the lawsuit and
that we've talked about before Donald
Trump once used money donated to the
Trump Foundation to buy a portrait of
Trump himself to decorate a golf course
of his right donations used to buy a
portrait to put up at a golf course that
Donald Trump owns and makes money from
and it's a form of money laundering and
just like with the Trump University
scandal Trump is tweeting that he won't
settle the case Donald Trump tweeted the
sleazy New York Democrats and they're
now disgraced and run out of town
attorney General Eric Schneiderman are
doing everything they can to sue me on a
foundation that took in eighteen point
eight million dollars and gave out to
charity more money than it took in
nineteen point two million dollars I
won't settle this case and of course he
did in the end settle the Trump
University case because Trump University
was exactly the scam that it was accused
of being they ended up settling for
something like twenty five million
dollars even though Trump said
he's not going to settle it and at some
point Trump is said that when you settle
you're basically saying that you're
guilty if you're not guilty you fight
and that's because we have a grifter as
president of the United States it's like
having that Rich Dad Poor Dad guy Robert
Kiyosaki as president of the United
States if you haven't heard of him look
him up or supplement salesman Alex Jones
as president of the United States or
some other con man because that's what
these are these are conmen and grifters
and there are sort of two double
standards that I think are important to
point out here first is the Hillary
Clinton double standard right because
Donald Trump famously said Hillary
Clinton should be in jail if I become
president we're gonna put her in jail
and investigate her everything so far
that Donald Trump is a accused Hillary
Clinton of doing he's guilty of himself
to a greater degree pay to play with the
Clinton Foundation Trump has way worse
pay-to-play stuff in his closet that
were learning about on an almost weekly
basis
Hillary is careless with classified
information well Trump spilled
classified information to a Russian spy
recruiter in the Oval Office Hillary was
careless with technology visa vie her
private email server while Trump is
using an unsecured iPhone that he flat
out refuses to have screened for hacking
attempts because it's inconvenience I
could go on with more examples but I
won't that's double standard number one
the Hillary double standard but there's
a second double standard which isn't
about Trump and Hillary but it's just
more general about rich people who have
a different set of rules and a totally
different set of standards period and
I've talked about this before and if
there's any satisfaction to be had from
this it is that hopefully running for
president will end up being the worst
decision that Donald Trump has ever made
because if he hadn't run for president
he might have never needed a smarter
lawyer than Michael Cohen which we now
know is not the case because his sketchy
dealings wouldn't have been under the
microscope to the degree that they now
are and hopefully it's going to be more
and more difficult for him to buy his
way out of some of this trouble because
he's President of the United States and
I say hopefully
but I actually don't know for sure in
fact it's possible because so far we
have seen this colloquially immoral
unethical and possibly legally criminal
behavior be normalised away by people
that are on the side of the president
and we've also seen a lack of real
political will to do something about it
by Republicans and we're going to talk
about this later on in the show but
ultimately it may come down to the
November 2018 election which is now only
five months away four and a half months
away whether we ever ultimately get
justice for the possible crimes of Trump
and his cronies this is the funniest
thing ABC News ran a special report
headline at the bottom of the screen
yesterday saying that former Trump
campaign chairman Paul Mann fort has
been indicted of and pled guilty to five
counts of manslaughter and of course
mana fort hasn't even been charged with
manslaughter at least not yet but it
made for a very funny few minutes of
confusion and I genuinely wonder how
this happens like were they preparing a
story that was actually about
manslaughter or were they preparing a
story about mana fort
pleading guilty to something other than
manslaughter but that doesn't really
make sense because mana for also didn't
plead guilty to anything I really am my
main curiosity is how did mana fort
pleads guilty to five counts of
manslaughter end up on the screen and it
is stepping right into the narrative
that Donald Trump has developed teeing
it up for Trump to hit out of the park
Trump immediately tweeting when this
happened look what fake ABC News put out
I guess they had it prepared from the 13
angry Democrats leading the witch hunt
hashtag stop the bias and of course as
far as we know this isn't related to
bias we don't have reason to think it
was a practical joke but it does set
Trump up perfectly and you can't help
Trump push the narrative right that is
what happens when you put this up on the
screen and I like when these things
happen because it's funny they get
called technical errors when it's not
really a technical error somebody
clearly messed up but it feeds right
into the Trump
of around fake news it was obviously a
fake Chiron if Paul Manafort was to kill
someone there would obviously be some
intent behind it and some planning
without you man and slaughter that's the
part that's not believable if mana forts
actions led to somebody's death it would
be murder not manslaughter for memory
everything we know about the guy but the
technical error News reporter ends up on
camera without pants and then this news
station will say we regret that there
was a technical error that took place
like well no the reporter wasn't wearing
pants that's not exactly a technical
thing we we regret the technical error
that occurred when our reporter shouted
racist obscenities during their report
really which piece of equipment caused
that to take place but in the end this
plays directly into Trump's fake news
narrative so it is unfortunate as much
as it is funny think you're gonna like
this one crime in Germany what do you
think on the rise on the decline has it
been steady we know about the
anti-immigrant far-right nationalist
parties of Europe they're all clamoring
about it's more more more crime more
crime all the time but is that true
Donald Trump apparently thinks so he
tweeted yesterday quote the people of
Germany are turning against their
leadership as migration is rocking the
already tenuous Berlin coalition crime
in Germany is way up big mistake made
all over Europe and allowing millions of
people in who have so strongly and
violently changed their culture that's
Trump's view the truth happens to be the
exact opposite of what Donald Trump said
we just got a new report last month
about German crime and it's at its
lowest level in 26 years since 1992 and
overall the crime rate has decreased in
Germany by about 5% from 2016 to 2017
that includes the number of politically
motivated crimes which are also down by
about 5% but the most notable category
of crimes that did go up anti-semitic
crime stemming of course from the
political right wing of Germany so think
about the circumstances Trump is wrong
that crime is up in Germany the one type
of crime that notably is up is an Tyson
crime which is the same type of crime
that's up in the United States as a
direct result of Donald Trump being
president and this sort of catalyzing
and coalescing and activating of the
anti-semitic white nationalist white
supremacist types who are feeling very
emboldened under Donald Trump similar
headline from the UK some time ago
anti-semitic crimes on the rise up
significantly in fact and there are
going to be the so-called skeptics about
this story anytime we do a story like
this they'd want to debunk the report
and they have some very very tired and
predictable talking points number one
they will say hey David the crime rate
is higher but police aren't recording
the crimes properly they haven't
presented evidence and that's a totally
unfalsifiable claim I don't think that's
a good argument against this report
number two another one they will say but
David the real number of crimes is
hidden because the population has
increased or something like that and of
course that makes no sense because the
report is about crime rates it's not
about the wrong number of crimes
it's about crime rates another one that
you will hear from the so-called
skeptics is David the reason the crime
rate is lower is because the police are
really bad at solving crimes but of
course the report is about reported
crimes not about solved crimes and the
police closing cases or not closing
cases doesn't actually have any bearing
on the crime rate there is however I
know Pat wants me to tell you what the
accurate criticism is of this study and
I'm gonna tell them Pat okay the fair
criticism of this study is that some
types of violent crime are not at twenty
six year lows in Germany right and and
that's true however that doesn't refute
the big picture of the study but there
are many many different types of crime
some types of crime are violent and some
are not and you can find some types of
violent crime that have increased in
Germany but what we can be 100% sure of
is that Donald Trump as usual just has
no idea what he's talking about have
another unfair criticism if you're
interested which is that even those the
statistics show crime is down in Germany
yeah it feels like
is up an Emer I remember Republicans
during the Obama administration would
make the same case about the economy
yeah all those these these numbers from
the Bureau of Labor Statistics show that
we're in a pretty good spot there's
little I feel like that yeah and of
course we know that facts do care about
your feelings contrary to what we hear
for many people on the right
apparently when it feels like they
should the facts very much care about
your feelings